je pense que tu devrais filmer
[Musique]
çaour je vaischer
[Rires]
son
attendez attendez pourquoi est-ce qu'on
cours attendez regardez ça regardez
ça regardez ça comment elle le matte
j'ai ma petite théorie sur ce truc c'est
comme un muscle mat
ça mec
merde là je crois qu'on est de plus en
plus fort elle croit qu'on lui a volé
elle s'est envolémin là c'est le black
qui a fait le coup c'est parce qu'on
s'entraîne rien ne peut nous arrêter où
tu vas ah ah ah tu es trop con non mais
sérieux je qu'est-ce qu'il a lui
c'est quoi son
[Musique]
problème mais es malade pourquoi tu as
fait ça c'est quoi ton
problème c'était un accident rassure-moi
[Musique]
Andrew je m'inquiète pour Andrew on peut
pas déconner avec ça c'est trop
dangereux Andrew c'est pas un
jeu
[Applaudissements]
arrête c'est quoi qui fait c'est vite
venez on descend Steve tu vas où attends
mat regarde ce truc oh